it's nice to see that you've all record
from the exam so well how many had two
cookies how many had no cookies that's
good oh there you fail alright today
we're going to go into agonizing detail
about what DNA viruses do to elaborate
the genetic information that's contained
in their genomes and by that I mean in
particular how do they transcribe RNA
from their DNA genomes and there are a
couple of points that are important and
they start with what if viruses taught
us as with everything that dr. a Canelo
has told you viruses of course teach us
everything well they teach us a lot but
they've yielded some very fundamental
information about control signals and
that is how various promoters are used
to initiate transcription and they've
told us informed us about what
constitutes a promoter that is what are
the DNA sequences that are recognized by
RNA polymerase the major protein that's
involved in generating transcripts and
all of the other ancillary proteins that
are very important in separating virus
from host promoters they've told us
about what an enhancer is and we'll get
into a little more detail about that
later but an enhancer is a magic
sequence it's something that does just
that it raises the initiation rate of
transcription and results in more RNA
being transcribed and there are some
very interesting properties of enhancers
they've also told us about introns and
exons and why nascent RNA transcripts
are bigger than messenger rnas and we'll
talk a lot about transcripts and we'll
talk about messenger RNAs and it's very
important to me that you understand what
the difference between those two is so I
will hammer that into your heads until
we're all sick of it and then finally
and perhaps most interestingly they've
told us how RNA synthesis is initiated
and regulated and they're very very
complex and intricate well-orchestrated
ways in which viruses use host proteins
and their own to recognize sequences
within their genomes to turn things on
to turn things off and to temporarily
regulate so we'll want to learn about
that so why is transcription important
it's usually one of the first events
that follows infection and it's like
that because viruses tend not to carry
with them all of the proteins that they
need to replicate themselves the DNA
virus chromosomes occur in a variety of
template's and when I say their
chromosome like that is they have some
of the properties but not all of the
properties of host chromatid for example
sv40 a member of the papaya virus family
and we've talked about that in terms of
replication the actual virus genome is
present as a regular array of
nucleosomes that is the virus DNA is
wrapped in that super coil around host
nucleosomes but what's amazing is that
there's a one particular area of that
virus genome the same area that's used
to initiate DNA synthesis the origin of
replication that leaves the virus genome
open for transcription I'd know viruses
and herpes viruses both linear molecules
in the virus have chromatin like DNA
instructions but they're not chromatin
per se rather they are decorated with
histones and other host proteins when
they come into the nucleus of the cell
but they don't form a chromatin like
structure and our friend HIV which is
RNA when it starts but DNA when it's
doing his business is transcribed from
integrated DNA so that virus RNA genome
has been made into a double-stranded DNA
template it is then integrated into the
host and it's from there that new virus
genomes and virus transcripts are made
and one of the things that's important
is that regulation of expression of
virus genetic information
is critical it's a strictly defined
series of events that rely on expression
of virus genetic information and
availability of host proteins now much
like DNA replication and I'll try and
draw the parallels for you so that you
can see where they are similar
regulation of transcription is generally
controlled by initiation although there
are points where elongation is a rate
limiting step and in particular in HIV
replication
there are RNAs that are small unless a
particular HIV protein is available and
we won't discuss that today it's a
multi-step process and there are many
opportunities for control transcription
is not just about starting like DNA
synthesis you need to form pre
initiation complex --is you have
complexes that are called closed and
open you have initiation events that are
abortive and so on and so forth
most of the specificity for
transcription however resides in
initiation the recognition of a precise
nucleotide sequence by virus and cell or
just cell in some cases proteins that
allows for transcription of that
termination is both occurs when both the
polymerase that's making RNA and the RNA
itself are released from the template
and as with most other instances of host
RNA transcription termination results
from recognition of a very specific
sequence which is conserved so we've
told you that the steps are just like
DNA replication that we have promoter
recognition think of that as the origin
with the formation of a pre initiation
complex which is where auxiliary
proteins recognize a sequence they bring
a polymerase to a site and they sit
there in they prime to initiate an
initiation occurs at a specific site a
demonstrated distance downstream from a
particular nucleotide sequence called at
a t-box
we then have elongation extension of the
growing RNA chain and termination and
then there are a series of other events
that occur so what happens to RNA
transcripts what is the transcript a
transcript is an RNA pol II nuclear tide
made from a DNA template in the nucleus
it is not a messenger RNA a messenger
RNA only exists in the cytoplasm on a
poly ribosome it's not a message until
it's bringing a Musset message okay you
can have that same sequence in the
cytoplasm but it's not technically a
messenger RNA until it's being
translated but in the biogenesis of
these RNA transcripts you have a number
of events that occur that ready this
transcript for transport from the
nucleus into the cytoplasm so let's just
look at them in a little bit of detail
while the RNA is being transcribed as
the 5 prime end is extended and released
from the template it is capped so this
particular moiety a 7 methyl guanosine
phosphate is placed on the 5 prime end
of the RNA so here's our transcript it
ends here usually it would end with a
triphosphate but what you get is this
backwards if you will sequence so the
base is extended and now you have a cap
and that cap is a structure which
protects the 5 prime end and which is
recognized by cap binding proteins which
facilitate translation after the RNA
reaches a certain point it gets
polyadenylated and that's a string of
poly a moieties that are added to the
end of the RNA and they tend to be
important for RNA stability many RNAs
have introns in them and there you have
to get removed they can be removed
during the course of transcription so
that you juxtapose two exons or they can
be removed post transcription some rnas
are edited the actual nucleotide
sequences are changed this all occurs
basically in the nucleus
but then in order for the RNA to become
functional or useful to the DNA virus it
has to be transported it has to get out
of the nucleus and in order to do that
it has to be recognized by some host
protein or later in the course of a
virus life cycle it can be a viral
protein and these proteins are called
export ins and they export RNA and they
do it in conjunction with a certain host
molecules as well once out in the
cytoplasm an RNA has a certain
functional half-life it can be
translated and made into protein any one
of the numbers of proteins at the virus
encodes or it can decay so the half-life
of that molecule is critical in terms of
where it's going one of the things that
we've learned the first in the last few
years is that some of these RNAs are
silenced and they're either silenced as
a result of expression of host micro
rna's small RNAs or virus RNAs and these
are used to regulate expression of these
messages and they result in either
degradation of the message or the
inhibition of its translation there are
three polymerases that are known to be
used in the biosynthesis of RNA in
mammalian cells one of them is
polymerase one and this makes ribosomal
RNA and it's not known to be used by
viruses per se it is used to make micro
rna's the other is paltu which is used
to make most artists that become
messenger rna's and also some micro RNAs
and then this polymerase three which
makes a series of molecules including
tRNAs but in the world of viruses it
makes RNAs such as the VA mRNAs of
adenovirus the Ebers of epstein-barr
virus and again some viral micro RNAs
and these are all regulatory
fuels rnase that end up controlling the
fate of messages and the production of
protein in virus infected cells so the
real question then becomes how does the
virus subjugate the host what's better
about the virus that makes it attractive
to the host replication machinery so it
depends upon what the virus is and how
it looks to the host
we've talked a little bit about
hepatitis B virus in order for that to
become a functional transcription unit
it has to complete the interrupted
strand of DNA adenovirus and
polyomavirus has just entered the cell
they bring nothing with them it's a
genome in the case of the polyomavirus
then there are nucleus ohms on it in the
case of AD know that linear DNA gets
coated with host histones and there's
some sort of a structure that's seen and
recognized by host transcription
apparatus herpes viruses at least herpes
simplex and a few of the other ones
actually bring something that's
encapsulated that's incorporated in the
India very own so it's not actually in
the capsid but in that layer between the
capsid and the envelope called the Teddy
mint and there are virus encoded
proteins that are present there and
they're very important for initiation of
specific genes in herpes virus
replication and retroviruses bring in
their own reverse transcriptase which
turns that RNA into a DNA and then
allows for production of a protein such
as integrase and the incorporation into
double-stranded DNA so why do we
regulate synthesis this says how but
it's just as much a why and that's to
control the timing and abundance of
specific virus proteins virus proteins
that are made very early time at very
early times an infection are there to up
regulate the expression of the virus
genome and at times to initiate or begin
the initiation of virus DNA synthesis so
you want those to be made early an
infection not late in infection you want
them there so that you increase the
number of
of virus templates why because an
orderly synthesis allows for specific
events if you want to go through a life
cycle and you want to make capsid
proteins the things that protect the
genome you want to do that after you
have a genome and the reason for that is
that in most cases these proteins
assemble efficiently and effectively
around the genome although some of them
are capable of self-assembly as dr. a
Canelo has told you the other reason is
that some of the gene products if made
in large amounts at the wrong time turn
out to be actually toxic to a cell if
you shut down the cell the host for the
virus the virus cannot faithfully
complete its mission so it gets
interrupted in the course of its
replication now what happens if things
go awry well it really depends on the
virus and it's something to think about
but in some instances when proteins are
elaborated at the wrong time the entire
transcriptional program shuts down and
you get what's called an abortive
infection one which starts but doesn't
finish its mission so what are the steps
in the transcription of pre messenger
RNA much like DNA replication and think
of this as an origin of replication
it's a promoter the transcriptional
machinery of the host recognizes this
DNA sequence and what it starts to do is
synthesize very small poly nucleotides
and many of these initiation events
abort so they are called abortive
initiations and the polymerase is
stalled at the initiation site until we
believe a bunch of things happen that
changed the polymerase changed the
family of proteins that are present on
the promoter and then it begins to move
down the DNA template and using
nucleotide triphosphates elongation
occurs elongation is also frequently
terminated and we have bigger abortive
transcripts so this process is not as
efficient as one would like it to be but
it seems to work because viruses make
lots of copies of themselves eventually
the nascent rnase begin to
accumulate and remember that we have
many polymer aces along the same genome
so this turkey like molecule has many in
front of it and many many in front of it
and many behind it and the 5-prime
nascent RNA is spit out it reaches a
point with this defined recognition
signal where the RNA synthesis is
terminated and two things happen the
polymerase falls off the DNA template
and the RNA transcript is released now
many other things go on as I alluded to
in that second or third slide during the
course of transcription seven methyl GPP
is added to the 5 prime terminal the
terminus of the transcription unit
that's the cap excellence and introns
are both transcribed and depending upon
the particular messenger RNA there are
end enucleate endonucleolytic events
that recognize the beginnings and the
ends of introns and result in their
removal splicing this can occur during
transcription or it can occur after
transcription is complete and the poly a
moieties are added the spliced RNAs and
not all viral RNAs are spliced in fact
many are not spliced very different from
the host where most are spliced they're
recognized by a series of promoters that
are proteins that are either virus or
host coded and they are pushed out
through the nuclear pores using export
ins and they accumulate in the cytoplasm
where they can be translated sometimes
we get viral RNAs that retain introns
sometimes they're just exon exon
boundaries and sometimes they have no
intervening sequence at all two things
happen they either get translated into
protein and then degraded or they can be
directly degraded so what composes or
what constitutes the recognition
elements for initiation of transcription
well we term these core and distal
elements and that refers to again DNA
recognition sequences that are either
close to the start site of
transcription core or just 11 an
additional element doesn't mean that
it's just upstream it can also be down
straight these core elements provide
information for recognition of the
assembly site and they usually contain
this sequence at a toe box so-called for
its obvious obvious reasons its sequence
and that's recognized by a protein tf2d
and you'll please don't memorize any of
these what I want you to know is that
there's a sequence of events and these
are named so because they come out as
column fractions and when they came out
on a column and then sometimes there is
a sequence called an initiator not
always and that specifies absolute
accurate starts and it turns out when
you look at the ends the five prime ends
of mammalian cell RNAs or viral RNAs
there's frequently a little bit of play
and they may start at one nucleotide or
one that's one upstream or one that's
one downstream from that there are these
distal sites that provide sites upstream
or downstream for activator proteins
proteins that enhance the initiation
event I enhance it because they're
bringing polymerase to the promoter well
because they actually interact with the
place and cause physical changes to the
polymerase and then we have enhances and
enhances of these magical sequences that
are position and orientation independent
in other words they can be upstream from
the start site downstream from the start
site and it doesn't matter whether they
are in headed in the same direction as
the transcription unit or the opposite
direction that is if you take that
element out of a genome and you put it
say it was upstream and you put it
downstream it will still function if you
turn it around it will still function
sometimes there tissue-specific
sometimes the universal when the
tissue-specific it's because there's a
protein that is recognizing that
enhancer element that's present only in
a particular tissue within the body
whereas could actually be species
specific as well so it can be something
that's present
in man but not other primates so this is
a schematic representation of what I've
talked about plus one always refers to
the start site for transcription and
frequently there is an initiated
sequence that encompasses the start site
or slightly downstream from it about 28
base pairs upstream from that start site
is the status sequence and this can't
these elements constitute the core
promoter so if you put those into an in
vitro transcription assay they will
generate RNA there are other sequences
though that are found between 100 and
500 and as many as thousands of base
pairs upstream that contain other DNA
binding sites or the sequences that bind
DNA binding proteins and they control
promoter activity or enhance or allow
for the presence of enhances or silences
so just like elements that activate
transcription there are elements that
temper it down and those are called
silencers we know less about how they
work so what is the virus DNA genome
have to do it has to enter the nucleus
because that's where the hosts
transcriptional apparatus lies the
templates and accessory proteins usually
hosts in most cases are recognized by
cell RNA polymerase and that leads to
either early or immediate early gene
expression and those are the proteins
again that either enhance gene
expression are involved in DNA
replication and subsequently that allows
for late transcription this template has
to produce a structure that's
recognizable by the transcription
apparatus of the host and that's to
generate these early genes and the
purpose of all this is to replicate
genomes to increase the template number
so if you come in with one borrowed you
know you want to make hundreds if you're
a virus you want to make hundreds
because you want to make more virus but
in order to make more virus you have to
make more messenger RNA and a lot more
protein and the easiest way to do that
and to subjugate the hosts is to put
more of yourself there increase the
template number and what that does is
like you can think of it as Brownian
motion but what it does is it offers
more opportunity for host RNA polymerase
--is and the transcription factories to
find these genomes one of the very
curious things that we learn as we go
forward and study these events is that
despite the fact that you can have
hundreds of genomes only a limited
number of them are actually being
transcribed the others are replicated
excuse me the others are acting as sinks
for host proteins that will temper virus
transcription so what does polymerase 2
do it's a very large complex assembly
the holoenzyme contains a number of
different proteins we're not going to
talk about all of them but we'll give
you a picture and an idea of what they
are they specify accurate initiation of
RNA transcripts they recognize the
promoter but they usually do it in
response to host and virus proteins so
isolated RNA polymerase by itself can
initiate transcription but not as
efficiently as what's in the pret
whereas when it's in the presence of
these other accessory molecules and they
synthesized RNA transcripts they do it
by recognition of that core promoter
element that small box a' conveys the
tata sequence and the 5 prime end for
initiation first by formation of a
stable closed initiation complex and
that locks the polymerase in place on
the DNA templates template then you form
an open initiation complex and just like
DNA replication you have a helix to open
in order to generate messenger RNA
excuse me transcripts you've got to be
able to read through the DNA
and then what happens is after you
generate this initiation complex the
polymerase actually escapes from the
promoter it begins to move downstream
and that happens because there's a
change of physical change to form a stew
that results from phosphorylation of its
carboxy terminus and that's done in a
variety of ways once promoter clearance
has been obtained the molecules along a
to get bigger and to get movement of the
polymerase complex this is different
from DNA replication where the complex
stays so there's an order of binding
again sort of think about what occurs
don't remember what the various names
are here's our core promoter is our
starch the site for transcription and
the tata box and this large complex of
proteins called tf2d tatah binding
factor plus transcription associated
factors binds and Benzes DNA so there's
actually a physical change in the
structure of the DNA all right Tata
binding protein recognizes the Tata box
through the initiator so there's
coordination between these two sequences
and then another protein enters tf2a
also enters into this complex and that
facilitates the binding whoops then we
have t f2f1 a polymerase so when this
protein comes in it allows RNA
polymerase this turkey over here to be
right next to this Turkey over here and
what you realize now is that you have a
lot of proteins in fact you have nine
proteins with ATPase and helicase
activity the ATP ASE's to generate
energy for the helicase to unwind the
template to allow the polymerase to
begin to form this closed RNA initiation
complex you now have all of these
proteins are raid and juxtaposed to one
another and it's now primed on the
promoter as a closed initiation complex
you then have to begin the initiation
prop
program so after recognition and
assembly we bend the DNA we unwind the
helix the polymerase remains in contact
with the promoter and then it begins to
incorporate nucleoside triphosphates and
begins to produce RNA sometimes there
are Board of transcripts and sometimes
we get we get things that move on down
through the template finally when this
opens you get release from the promoter
so that allows this assembly the
polymerase assembly not the initiator
assembly to move down the polymerase
down the template this alright the
initiation moieties if you will remain
bound to the DNA and they allow for new
polymerase molecules to now be added at
the initiation site there are a bunch of
assays that are used for promoter
activity and I'm going to show you some
of the good things - some of the bad
things about them there's something
called a runoff assay and that's done in
a test tube
there is pulse labeling where one
incorporates radioactive nucleotides
into growing RNA chains and that's
really the only thing that measures
promoter activity where absolute
strength the others are all synthetic if
you will and there were reporter assays
that use molecules whose product we can
measure very easily because it emits
light or because it has an enzymatic
activity and we quantitate the amount of
that product that's made when we say
that that is a reflection of the
promoter activity what it is is a
reflection of the amount of messenger
RNA that accumulates and it doesn't
account for a lot of things but it's
it's usually a pretty good approximation
so what's a what's the in vitro assay
like what happens is we take a DNA
template that contains our promoter of
interests usually one that has been
cloned and amplified in a plasmid and
then we'll linear linearize
that plasmid so we take the circular
molecule we make it linear and we make
it rather short usually you're on the
order of about 100 base pairs and we
allow that piece of DNA we introduced
that piece of DNA into a test tube with
our transcription apparatus and
radioactive nucleotide triphosphates we
let this reaction go on for a little
while and we measure the amount of unit
length RNA that's made and we can see it
because it incorporates radioactive
nucleotides and this is a representation
of that so that's done in vitro but
that's done outside of all of the
structural apparatus that's present
inside of a cell so just like DNA
replication occurs at specific sites in
the nucleus so does transcription the
reporter assay involves fusing a coding
sequence of interest in this case
firefighte luciferase behind a promoter
of interest and we can change this
promoter and then we transform this DNA
into a cell where it can be transient li
expressed one of the problems with this
assay is that you get thousands if not
millions of copies of DNA present inside
of a cell that takes up these DNA's and
then after a period of time we make an
extract and we add luciferin and ATP and
we measure luciferase si and we ask this
promoter a make more luciferase the
promoter B or what and this of course is
subject to other interpretations as well
but these are ready assays that are
easily done in a laboratory and they
tend to give us they atleast inform us
in one direction or another now there
are lots of different ways of regulating
transcription one way and perhaps the
most important is to regulate abundance
that is the sheer amount of a specific
RNA that accumulates through initiation
you can regulate transcription by the
availability of the template and some
parts of a DNA template are available at
all times in other parts or not they're
either occluded by host proteins or by
some structural elements sometimes the
co-activators that they
that bring the polymerase to the
promoter are decorated that is they have
other moieties that are added to them
and they can be phosphorylation events
methylation events set elation events or
adp ribosylation and we know that the
role of enhancers can change the rate of
initiation
what's splicing let's just be clear
about where it came from and why it's
important in a regulating control of
virus RNA early in the or late in the
60s there were experiments done that
compared the size of RNA that was
present in the nucleus of a mammalian
cell to the size of the rnas that
accumulated in the cytoplasm with the
exception of the ribosomal units and
what they found was that nuclear RNA
also known as heterogeneous nuclear rnas
were much much larger than the messenger
rnas had accumulated and it was tough to
figure out why and there was a whole
bunch of stuff that went on for years
and years and years and we didn't know
what it was but what we knew was that
these heterogeneous nuclear rnas had
both five-time caps and 3-prime poly a
sites so they looked just like what
accumulated in the cytoplasm and became
translated they looked like they were
going to be messengers the early hints
that this was not true came from studies
of adenovirus late on rnas and what they
found was that there were eight seven or
eight different late RNAs that are used
to generate the capsid structure of the
virion and they all had the same
nucleotide sequence at the 5 prime end
the question became how and why and it
turns out that all of these late RNAs
have four parts one part which is three
parts that one is a five prime terminal
tripartite leader and we'll explain what
that is in a couple of minutes and the
second part is the body that is
part that actually encodes the protein
of interest so four parts the five prime
terminal try part leader and the body so
how do you get smaller rnase from big
rnase you do it through splicing and
this is an adenovirus transcription map
and what's important for me to tell you
about is that there is one transcription
unit very close to the origin region of
DNA synthesis called ena that is
recognized by host proteins and host
proteins alone and it contains an
enhancer and that's the first RNA that's
transcribed from adenovirus DNA and it
is absolutely essential because what it
does is it activates transcription of e
to an early gene product so this is an
immediate early gene product in E 2 and
E 2 begins to start the DNA replication
cycle and that allows for the synthesis
of late RNAs so why is why is this
different there's a promoter in the
middle of the adenovirus chromosome
called the major late promoter at very
very early time supposed to infection a
single very long RNA is made from this
and sometimes a short RNA is made for it
in other words the promoter is active
but no late gene products accumulate
after a period of time this gene for a
to which is made after DNA synthesis is
protein is extract is translated from
this RNA and that activates this
major-league promoter and what happens
now is that the transcription units
begin to assemble in a much more
cohesive manner and we don't really
understand this but various portions of
the major late promoter region part
transcribed so we have what's called l1
l2 and l3 and they are separated by RNA
that is removed so the
these are functional equivalents of
exons although they don't encode any
protein and these are intervening
sequences that are removed from them so
this is the tripartite leader and this
is an important sequence because it's
used to help translate late messenger
RNAs the three prime end of whoops the
three prime end of l3 is then spliced to
various acceptor sequences throughout
the very large messenger RNA to generate
individual RNA transcripts and we'll
talk about those in a little bit more
detail how do we know this is actually
true I told you before that all of the
late transcripts so if you isolated RNAs
for l2 or l3 hexerin or core proteins
and you asked what is that v prime and
look like they would all look the same
so this undec a nucleotide was conserved
how could that be derived well when they
looked at the sequence of adenovirus
what they saw was that these sequences
were incorporated within this tripartite
leader and what this is a picture of is
a dna-rna hybrid and what they've done
is take a single strand of adenovirus
DNA in blue and annealed it to hex on
messenger RNA and what they see is and
let's look at the back end of the
molecule this represents double-stranded
RNA DNA duplex so a portion of it is
linear collinear and forms a hybrid but
the very v prime n contains little areas
one two and three of duplex and areas of
DNA that are extended from the template
and they're extended because they don't
hybridize with the RNA there's no RNA
there so they've been removed so the
tripartite leader is contained within
sequences 1 2 & 3 and the sequences
between them and the body of whatever
RNA it is or loop down and that's how we
knew that was the first evidence that
these things were spliced
three people who're accorded Nobel
prizes based on this work so splicing is
value-added we've talked about how virus
genomes can serve genetic information
and here we have transcripts conserving
genetic information because depending
upon where they are spliced you get a
different protein that resolves from it
so splicing occurs without loss of
coding information it's very economical
you can splice at different sites within
the same transcripts and generate
multiple rnas that will change the coded
product of that RNA so alternative
splicing that is the use of different
acceptors and donors creates new
functional genes by a rearrangement of
exons and thus expands the coding
information of a small virus genome so
now let's look in a little bit more
detail at what goes on and add no here's
that major late transcript and here are
five different potential coding regions
and you can see that they are generated
from this transcript by the donate the
spliced donor here at the end of this
sequence joining an acceptor somewheres
downstream to generate l1 l1 and l2 l3
or what have you and depending upon
where the splices occur you get
different families of RNA in fact
sometimes the splices occur within genes
and again you get different proteins
made as a result of that and those
proteins may be collinear and they may
diverge over portions of that message
and we'll show you an example of that
when we talk about even a HIV generates
it's very important regulatory proteins
all as a result of splicing and it's
splicing is controlled in part by some
of its own proteins they control
elongation of transcription from viral
DNA that's incorporated into the
integrated into the genome and they also
control where and when splicing occurs
remember that with a retrovirus you have
to make a full-length RNA transcript in
order to generate a genome you also have
to make partial length of transcripts to
make the various proteins so let's go
back to sv40 we learned all about how it
replicates its DNA and the nice thing
about it is that the same sequence
that's important for initiation of DNA
secret DNA synthesis is also important
for the initiation of early
transcription and the resulting
synthesis of T antigen the sv40 genome
contains the molecule called an enhancer
it was the first enhancer that was ever
described and it's a duplicated 72 base
pair sequence and as I said before it's
a sequence that works at a distance or
it can its orientation independent and
it can work in trans doesn't have to be
physically linked to the sequence that's
being transcribed and if you look at it
schematically this is the sv40 origin of
DNA replication area it's that open non
chromatin aizen area of the super coiled
molecule here is the early transcription
start site and this sequence serves as
the enhancer sequence which binds a
whole bunch of host proteins and they
work in conjunction with host RNA
polymerase to initiate transcription of
early RNA how do enhancers work well
this is what we think there are their
upstream or downstream in some cases
they can be ninety thousand base pairs
away from the promoter but what they do
is they actually recognize sequences
within the initiation complex and these
proteins bend DNA and bind to it and
what they do is they increase the
affinity of RNA polymerase for these
sites and ergo they increase initiation
how do we know they work in trans and
this is a very clever experiment where a
piece of DNA that contained the core
sequence was isolated by restriction
endonuclease digestion
so we have a definite end and we have
our start site and the relative
transcription of this in an in vitro
assay as it was measured and that's one
when you add the enhancers you get one
hundred times that amount of
transcription
if you digest that sequence that
contains the enhancer and edie a biotin
moiety to the end Biden is this sticky
substance then you go back to one so if
these two pieces of DNA are not together
we're not able to find each other
there's a better case then what happens
is it's the same as having only the core
sequence now you can physically join
them but prevent movement of anything by
adding a molecule called streptavidin
which is has tremendous avidity for
biotin and now you form this structure
where you have physically linked the two
pieces of DNA but no molecule can go
from here to here so it can't go down
the railway track but it can cross the
railway tracks and when you put these
things together in this composition then
you restore about 60% of the activity
and what that tells you is that the
enhancer activity can work trans to the
actual molecule because it can't
transmit a signal through the bound
moiety
now how is transcription regulated by
host proteins viruses use the host or
virus specified proteins to regulate
expression they're either encode them
and they encode them very early in the
infection process or they bring them in
with Co activating molecules when you
bring a molecule in then you limit it
six its accessibility to DNA in general
on the basis of what kind of cell type
it's in so cell type specificity can
limit expression and as I said before
for the case of enhances which recognize
certain host proteins these molecules
can be organ or species specific so an
enhancer from a mouse may or may not
work in a human cell and vice versa
what are the regulatory protein domains
that are present in some of these
activator molecules well most of these
regulatory molecules are composed of
multiple domains they're not simple
one-shot proteins and they contribute to
virus DNA transcriptional regulation in
many ways some of them are DNA binding
motifs and some of these are called
zinc fingers helix-turn-helix motif or
basic residues some of these proteins
have activator or repressor activities
that is things that turn up
transcription or turn it down and they
usually do these through acidic domains
things that are glutamine rich prolene
Reed rich or isoleucine rich and more
often than not these regulatory
molecules don't function as you know
molecular species rather they're dimers
or trimers in the case of T antigen into
hexamer so they multum arise and these
sequences not only can bring together
the virus proteins but they can help
them interact with other proteins what
are some of the virus transcriptional
activators that we should know a little
bit about some are order regulatory
molecules such as sv40 t antigen after
you synthesize T antigen it goes back it
sits at the site of initiation of
transcription and DNA replication in
this case and it actually down regulates
expression of itself too much T is
apparently not a good thing herpes
simplex virus produces a major immediate
early protein called ICP 4 that
activates gene expression of the bulk of
transcription units in the virus but
turns its own self wolf so it's Auto
regulatory some of these regulatory
molecules bind DNA T antigen ICP for the
e2 protein from papilloma virus that we
talked about and the Epstein
virus nuclear antigen which is important
in regulation of epstein-barr virus
some of them bind host proteins so
herpes simplex virus brings in with the
infectious virus particle a protein
called vp-16
that's the protein that's present in the
segment and it works through a variety
of host proteins to activate immediate
early gene expression and we'll go
through that in some detail and some
liber8 host transcriptional activators
just like T antigen is important in
releasing the host from cell cycle
constraints it's also important for
releasing host transcriptional proteins
and sv40 T does this adenovirus one
does this and papilloma virus each seven
do it and they all do it on the same
protein and they all do it in slightly
different ways and that protein is RB
for the retinoblastoma protein it's an
important tumor suppressor and a
regulator of cell cycle but what RB does
is it captures a host protein called e
to F and sequester's it so when that is
released it's now available for
transcription from the virus genome
these proteins all interact with
polymerase ii and the purpose is to
establish a regulatory circuit both
positive auto-regulatory loops that
alter the rate of transcriptional
initiation and virus proteins can
stimulate this and negative
auto-regulatory loops that repress gene
expression we don't really understand
this in great detail we believe that
it's a result of the proteins actually
physically and strongly binding to the
DNA and preventing promoter clearance
but the most important thing they do is
initiate transcriptional Cascades and
for almost all viruses that we have
studied transcriptional units are
activated in a fixed sequence so you
have one family of genes that's turned
on a second family of genes that's
turned on later and the third family of
genes turned on after DNA replication so
if you look at the positive and negative
order regulatory loops we look at our
gene gene
and it gets transcribed and it makes
protein X protein X can do one of two
things it can go back and sit on this
promoter and dampen expression dampen
transcription from that gene or it can
go back and it can actually activate
transcription so those are positive and
negative auto-regulatory loops by a
production of that protein the other
thing that with these proteins can do is
to initiate a cascade of a regulation
gene X in this case is recognized by
cellular components viral RNA is made
the protein is then expressed it goes
back into the nucleus and instead of
sitting down on itself
it recognizes other promoters gene y&z
would have you and it activates their
transcription normally this gene is
silent and it's silent until this
protein is made but activation of this
regulatory cascade turns this gene on
and that differentiates an immediate
early gene one that's made right after
virus infection from an early gene one
that's made as a result of expression of
a virus protein these transcriptional
Cascades allow for transcription of
viral genes in a reproducible and
temporally controlled manner gene X is
made period of time goes by gene wise
made another period of time goes by DNA
replication ensues we've differentiated
between immediate early and early
proteins and then we have transcription
of late teens some late teens are made
at the beginning of DNA replication some
of them are made at the end of DNA
replication in most cases we don't know
what separates those two events but this
transcriptional cascade ensures
coordinated production of DNA genomes
structural proteins so you can make
infectious virus and what it does is
freeze templates from repressors as I
said before when you make lots of DNA
molecules and you have lots of genomes
present in a Cell any host proteins that
are there to repress the virus
viciously repressed cuz they're not
really there to do that
Arnav soaked up by all these genomes and
so now you free
the virus promoters for their
transcription and activating proteins
can induce transcription of both host
and viral genes and sometimes you need
to turn on something that the host makes
as well and repress transcription of
their own genes so let's look at three
different paradigms for this we've
discussed sv40 in a little bit of detail
and what I've told you is that at that
origin of DNA replication
you have an early transcription unit and
that encodes large T antigen once T is
made you dampen expression from the
early promoter and you activate
expression from the late and we believe
that's via an aunty repression mechanism
with adenovirus we first make an
immediate early protein II one a and
that interacts with host proteins to
release a transcriptional protein called
e to F which allows for transcription of
e to e to is a DNA polymerase
single-stranded DNA binding protein
series of molecules and they result in
synthesis of adenovirus DNA anti
repression of that major late promote
promoter activation of 4a to and late
transcripts and herpes does it a little
bit differently it carries in in with it
in the very on this molecule VP 16 and
that recognizes in concert with a series
of host proteins which we'll talk about
immediate early gene promoters all
immediate early gene promoters carry a
common Decca nucleotide sequence and
that's recognized in concert with a host
and that results in expression of a
couple of immediate early proteins one
this IC p4 which can both negatively and
positively regulate gene expression and
one IC p0 which is a promiscuous
transcriptional activator
this protein will activate almost any
promoter known to man
so it's a very efficient molecule and
turning on genes and these activate the
early cascade and again we make
replication proteins we make DNA we go
into the late phase talking about the
complexity of these units we see that
sv40 is a very small genome it has two
transcription units and early and a late
they make six proteins heavily relies on
the host to initiate transcription and
DNA replication and splicing generates
all of the RNAs that are found in sv40
infected cells adenovirus is
considerably larger it has a
transcription units that encode 40
proteins and you'll recall that these a
large number of these proteins are
derived as a result of splicing from
that large single messenger RNA you make
multiple transcripts herpes virus is
considerably larger it has a t
transcript units and they encode more
proteins and so the layers of complexity
are greater and greater the one thing
that all of these things have in common
is that the promoters that are used for
the very first events interact after an
introduction into the nucleus and
immediate early gene expression or in
the case of sv40 early are very
complicated they controlling multiple
sites for binding of host proteins and
the reason for that should be pretty
obvious what that does is allows them
access to virtually any cell type it
allows them to use many different kinds
of activating molecules that may be
present in the liver but not in the
heart in the brain but not in the spleen
so it adds diversity to the ability of
these viruses to transcribed and as I
said before some of these
transcriptional activators auto regulate
and others just activate here's a
picture of se for T so you can think
about it in a little more detail and
these are differentiates between the
early units which makes
two proteins large T and small T and the
late unit that makes structural elements
parts of the virion and you'll see
they're all made from the same sequence
and they're all derived as a result of
splicing to make various length proteins
and in some cases they actually overlap
but encode different proteins so the
sequence for VP 1 and vp 3 is the same
it's the reading frame that's different
how does T work again it binds the
origin is a hexamer that results in
dampening the early promoter and
activating the late promoter so that
early transcripts are decreased relative
to late and you need more and more of
that because you only need a certain
amount of protein to make new DNA
molecules but you need lots of protein
to make new variants adenovirus is a bit
different there are three virus proteins
and DNA synthesis that govern govern the
phase transitions the immediate early
gene synthesis the early gene synthesis
and the late p1a is necessary for
transcription of all early transcription
units and it's necessary because of its
interaction with RB e 2 is required for
DNA synthesis and that's the early gene
product and that's important because
without it you don't enter into the late
transcription phase which increases
initiation from the major late promoter
and 4a to is a late protein which
enhances late-teen transcription so it's
made very early on after DNA replication
and it enhances gene transcription so
I've highlighted these in red p1a comes
first transcription unit II when B
follows it very shortly afterwards but
even a expression results in activation
of the e to e promoter and when e to e
is made you make DNA binding protein pre
terminal protein and polymerase and then
you get DNA replication and you activate
for a 2
and the major league promoter so those
are the idle virus transcription units
II one a is actually a family of gene
transcripts and because of differential
splicing you get two different protein
products out of them one which is two
hundred and eighty-nine amino acids on
one which is two hundred and forty three
they used the same splice acceptor so
the C terminus is composed of the same
sequences but they differ in terms of
their splice donor so the large protein
contains this moiety Co 3 which is
important for stimulating early gene
transcription and both the large and the
small moiety have sites that bind host
proteins RB and another transcriptional
regulatory protein called P 300 these
proteins don't bind to DNA but they do
bind various host activating factors and
one of these called mediator 23 binds
and assembles RNA polymerase in the
initiation complex so this protein
stimulates initiation and it does it in
an indirect manner via its interaction
with DNA but it also works to release B
to F which is bound by RB so in a normal
adenovirus promoter you have e to F
which recognizes DNA found on that
promoter but covered with RB when a when
a comes along it releases or be from
that complex so it takes the RB off and
allows me to F now to be seen e to F
works to bring RNA polymerase to the
site and to activate the promoter so it
takes the promoter from being turned off
repressed by a host protein to being
activated and it does it by stripping RB
and allowing e to F to remain bound to
DNA
now for something incredibly simple this
is the herpes simplex virus replication
cycle what I'd like to point out to you
is the events that occur and tell you in
a little more detail about some of them
so here's our virus it's got this
beautiful envelope around a tenement
around a capsid around its DNA it binds
to specific receptors and then it this
gorgeous these proteins into the
cytoplasm one of them is responsible for
shutting off the host and we won't go
into how it does that but the other is
this guy vp-16
and as the capsid is finding its a way
along actin and Dyna 'men filaments to
the nucleus and extruding its DNA
circular izing it as you'll recall vp-16
is interacting with a host protein
called h CF and that allows it to get to
the nucleus vp-16 is not per se a DNA
binding protein but once it in
conjunction with these other host
proteins get together they recognize
sights on virus dean DNA that encode v
immediate early gene products and that
activates their transcription
transcripts go out into the cytoplasm
they're made the proteins come back and
these proteins are responsible for
initiating excuse me for activating the
early replication cycle they go back out
into the cytoplasm to turn beta proteins
or early proteins they come into the
nucleus and they begin to replicate DNA
it's a DNA polymerase and all of those
accessory proteins that we talked about
last week new transcripts are made from
this concatenate DNA and they go again
out into the excuse me new transcripts
are made to go out into the cytoplasm
and these encode predominantly
structural proteins and glycoproteins
glycoproteins remain in the cytoplasm
the structural proteins go into the
nucleus where they set assemble around
viral DNA and then the virus buds once
from the nucleus where it attains a
nuclear envelope then it D envelops and
goes back out into the side
plasm and it rien de lips and buds from
the host so it's a very complex picture
but what's important is that as it goes
back out from the nucleus it gains a
tenement again and so this particle that
came in is captured as this thing buds
out of the nucleus and is now available
in infectious particles the replication
cycle is initiated by v6 vp-16 it
activates immediate early transcription
these proteins control transcription
from all virus genes if you destroy
their activity during the course of
virus infection you stop transcription
their expression leads to early gene
synthesis and DNA synthesis then
expression of delayed late and late
genes and these are dependent on DNA
replication with packaged vp-16 it's at
the Nuvi around when we start the cycle
all over again and this whole thing can
be summarized by saying that there is
coordinate regulation of virus gene
expression in a temporal fashion a
follows B follows C what is vp-16
it's a protein it has a potent C
terminal acidic activator it does not
bind DNA but it only works when the
promoter of interest contains this DNA
sequence called attacker at motif and
this motif is present in herpes simplex
virus immediate early promoters it
associates when it comes into the cell
in the cytoplasm with something called h
CF host cell factor it's very
interesting that in neurons and we'll
talk about this again later in the
course where the virus tends to go
latent or frequently goes laden h CF is
not present in the cytoplasm it's only
in the nucleus and so the vp-16 can't
associate with it what it infects the
neuron and there are other physical
obstacles to that and the other protein
that it interacts one with is acht one
and these two proteins provide
specificity for the promoter when this
tripartite moiety is on DNA it
stimulates initiation and elongation of
transcription and this is specific for
immediate early promoters so here's what
goes on the virus DNA contains this
sequence
the tadka rat sequence the 5-prime
portion of it has turned an octamer
sequence and the grat motif the protein
och 1 cell protein recognizes the
octamer sequence and it binds DNA so
this is a DNA recognition sequence vp-16
is bound to HCF once it binds then we
have a conformational change and these
proteins can now sit down next to och
one recognizing this sequence and this
changes physically changes and bends the
DNA the DNA allowing once again for
initiation of transcription promoter
recognition so you now have a quaternary
complex that's formed as a result of
recognition of a viral DNA motif by two
host proteins in in conjunction with a
virus protein now as I said to you at
the beginning of the lecture a primary
transcript does not become a messenger
RNA until it's exported export is
usually accomplished by oops
export is usually accomplished by host
proteins and the transport uses and the
transcript uses nuclear pores to exit a
protein complex that marks mature rnase
core export from the nucleus is
assembled during splicing so this is an
active event specific signals are
recognized within RNA by host and/or
viral proteins and this allows for
tagging the molecule for bringing it out
into the cytoplasm these these export
ins the host proteins or the viral
protein shuttled between the nucleus so
they used cattle look politically they
go back and forth and they carry their
cargo from the nucleus into the
cytoplasm where they're released and
then translated there are many rnas that
are not spliced in virus infected cells
retroviruses herpes viruses ortho mixer
viruses produced on spliced rnas and
they too are exported for translation
for ovarian assembly and one of the
examples of this is a herpes virus
protein called ICP 27 and it acts as a
Sharon to ferry most virus messenger
RNAs across the nucleus because most of
them are not spliced
so they're not seen as Botta fighty
structures by the host mechanism and how
do we know this well we know what about
this protein is that it's a nuclear
phosphoprotein it has a nuclear export
signal so they'll be taken out of the
nucleus so that tells you that these
proteins need that it has a nuclear
localization signal so then go back into
the nucleus and it has two regions that
bind RNA happens to have other features
that are important virus expression and
it's required for polyadenylation of
virus messages but for this purpose we
want to talk about shuttling the
movement from the nucleus grabbing an
RNA that doesn't have an inter
intervening sequence in it so it hasn't
been marked and bringing it into the
cytoplasm so how do we know it doesn't
if we
look at this picture this is a picture
of cells that have been infected with a
virus that expresses a protein that's
temperature sensitive so at the elevated
temperature the protein is made and
accumulates only in the nucleus and it
never leaves the nucleus it's
recognizing RNA but it's not moving out
and because it can't physically do it
when you raise the temperature you see
that these little dots that were all
nuclear now expand into the cytoplasm
you can see a dull green haze are in it
so these guys can now excuse me when we
lower the temperature these guys can now
move from the nucleus back at it to the
cytoplasm they then get shuttled back
into the nucleus and we utilized to
export more RNAs and finally I just want
to emphasize something about late gene
expression sometimes DNA replication is
sufficient sometimes it's just enough to
activate the promoters and we see that
with sv40 in the case of adenovirus this
gene product for a is transcribed
because viral DNA synthesis tight rates
at a repressor again lots of genomes you
take away the host ability to turn
things down and then this protein
cooperates with another viral protein to
stimulate transcription from the major
late promoter and you get these long
transcripts that can generate
capsid proteins so what do you need to
take away from today's lesson
transcription is complicated
alright there are lots of ways of
starting the molecule there are lots of
sequences that are important there are
lots of host proteins there are virus
proteins they interact with each other
and they like to do that and they like
to do it because they want to get things
started
control is it at many levels not just
that starting the first family of
transcription units but the later
families and sometimes they depend upon
expression of gene products and or DNA
replication there are always host
protein
that are involved and they help regulate
transcription and in almost every case
that we know about virus gene expression
is coordinate regulated in the temporal
manner thank you